hallo leute wir sind heute zurück in der
küche allerdings koch über heute nicht
sondern bereiten mit euch einen cocktail
vor
oder besser gesagt einen statt hier habt
diesen kurzen vielleicht schon einmal in
einer bar in deutschland getrunken
wir machen heute mit euch mexikaner los
geht's
[Musik]
mexicana besteht hauptsächlich aus zwei
getränken
das ist eine klare spirituosen wie
beispielsweise kommt oder wir nutzen
heute bobka und das ist tomatensaft dann
nutzen wir für den mexikaner noch st
rita das ist ein getränk aus
verschiedenen frucht und gemüsesäften
mit gewürzen unter mitte mexikaner auch
hinter schön scharf ist kommt natürlich
auch tabasco hinzu außerdem noch salz
und pfeffer und einige geheime zutaten
denn jeder der mexikaner macht jeder bar
besitzer hat immer eine bestimmte
geheime zutat dir nicht verraten wird
das machen wir heute auch so für das
pürieren der tomaten nutzen wir einen
mixer dh wir haben die tomaten jetzt
schon in den mixer gefüllt jetzt kommt
der deckel drauf und jetzt hoffen wir
dass nicht leicht die ganze küche rot
ist und schau mal ob das funktioniert
[Musik]
aber es kommt drauf an
wunderbar sehr gut so wir haben jetzt
einen großen kochtopf und werden nun
alle zutaten zusammen schütten
jetzt nehmen wir erst mal den wodka
macht dann ganz viel tomatensaft dann
kommt der song guitar 1
und jetzt geht es gleich los
tabasco ich werde mal ein bisschen
versuchen aber ich mag eigentlich nicht
so gerne scharfes essen wir werden sehen
okay okay jetzt werden wir gleich
abschmecken mit salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
fun fact der sogenannte mexikaner wurde
tatsächlich in deutschland erfunden
ein gastronom aus hamburg hat diesen in
den 80er jahren in seiner hard rock
kneipe entwickelt und ausgeschenkt und
heute ist der mexikaner von den bars
nicht mehr wegzudenken es ist ein
kultgetränk geworden
so jetzt werden wir alles schön
verrühren sie ein bisschen aus wie
tomatensuppe ist es aber nicht
und jetzt zum schluss kommt noch unsere
geheime zutaten zu
so jetzt geht es an das testen
man soll mexikaner eigentlich erst mal
stehen lassen für eine nacht da ich aber
natürlich schauen will ob da was
geworden ist trinken wir jetzt einfach
schon mal eine zeit natürlich sehr viel
mexikaner
das mache ich jetzt damit am besten
organisiere ich noch spontan eine party
oder schick ein bisschen eine flasche
mexikaner nach berlin zog a really freut
sich die freut sich auch so jetzt
schauen wir mal was dieser selbst
gemachte mexikaner kann mein kameramann
hat noch nie ein getrunken
ost
so
habt ihr auch schon einmal mexikaner
getrunken dann verratet uns doch mal in
den kommentaren wie euch der geschmeckt
hat wenn ihr jetzt noch mehrere kabel
lernen wollt dann probiert doch mal
unsere app sieht lecker aus
dort könnte unter anderem eure
aussprache verbessern
ihr nehmt euch selbst auf und vergleicht
euch dann mit der aussprache eines
muttersprachler
so könnt ihr eure aussprache schritt für
schritt verbessern
bis bald
[Musik]